SHIVA SHARIF BIDABADI: So I'm Shiva.
I'm doing post-grad studies in Department of Electrical
and Computer Engineering of Curtin.
My project is trying to find a way or a system
to be used in early identification of abnormalities in the walking gait
patterns.
Dropping of the forefoot happens due to the different reasons.
For example, weakness in the muscles or pressure on the nerve.
This problem, foot drop can cause different problems for old people,
for example.
They can be ended up in falling to the ground.
But in young persons can cause problems such as limitation in the sports
and those kind of things.
So what we are trying to do is having a device
to capture these movements from the patients
once they come into the clinical area.
But in future, one of the future steps of the project
can be having this device get used at home
during the daily activities of the subjects,
once they are doing their normal daily movements.
And this system can be directly connect to the internet
and the data can be captured.
This system is going to be a user-friendly system, which
is low in cost and also portable and lightweight
to be used by the patients or old people.
So comparing to the previous methods of gait analyzing,
it's way cheaper and more easy to use.